before this video begins to have an
important announcement there's gonna be
a new green-screen competition
green-screen competition number two is
happening all the info is down in the
description basically I recorded myself
with a green-screen I want you to edit
me and in and the most creative and
funny edits will make it into a video
that I react to him all the info is in
description check it out I can't wait to
see what you make this one is
interesting last week I played your
games they were top quality meme he's
just like the finest potato ma I'm so
excited we had three more games
Michael Welsh me out he played through
all of them and he says this is the best
one so we're gonna have to see this game
is called Malcolm 1466 adventure please
kill me right now let's go on an
adventure with Mackin like the undertale
music I'm too rich I bought it what does
it it's min to win they had a board yeah
what do they do Malcolm what do they do
shut up Jessica choose a name for your
YouTube channel I didn't know making
videos was that hard
in 1875 so I should name myself oh wait
he's brilliant in YouTube world what the
[ __ ] man what I'm playing his Malcolm
this is me is he sleeping hey wake up
and tell me where I am
I love the Avatar so useful Monica hey
I'm PO - pi
did you ever shave if I don't want to
shave out of shaved your fat Punk Jesus
Christ
don't call me fat because you're afraid
to die up here
I'm crying let's find him let's fight
back
food fight brofist Malcolm - oh Jesus
Christ Malcolm has lost I'm gonna
destroy you yeah what's that it's me
Peter Pan sponsor ego
don't destroy the McDonald boy he
probably is Sydney I don't know the
voice for sponsor Rica he probably is
the new chosen one yeah he can't be more
over you're a terrible creature
torturing such a poor innocent youth
you're right
I will not make the same mistakes Thank
You sponsor ego completely you fallen
into the YouTube world a place where you
can become famous and rich but also
hated by it's very true I am the ruler
of this world this I am the richest man
of the other world thanks to my channel
and my billions of accounts but there is
a prophecy one day a new king will fall
down here and save Peter by by becoming
great on YouTube in order to do that you
will have to find and climb their wall
of dicks I will come back to you when
you reach the wall
Hey whoa playing the song I made oh man
I miss the Sun I gotta climb it yeah
you're sure that this come on Jennifer
get the [ __ ] out of the way it is
written I can't breathe
that's my grave who said that
oh is that me oh this that's we're
potato fell oh you that's not the most
important where you should know is that
climbing the wall is not the best way to
become famous you have to be sure that
it's what you want before going this way
trust me
sucking dicks is tiring and can blow
your mind if you're not prepared enough
you seem to be filled with determination
yeah I read it's claimed the world digs
goodbye I'm a student Jennifer
you can let him pass if you see poets
tell him that I love him
you can welcome in here
please sing come back again oh we're
climbing the wall Dick's come on you can
do it this is amazing this is so good
this is beautiful this is game is true
art developer didn't want to put dicks
in this game this gate leads to the top
of the wall
this game sucks I hate this game Malcolm
are you always so upset
hello there's a toilet there you made it
yeah I know they were sitting in Eugene
now for the final test when you destroy
the world I get to choose
I will go yes cuz I'm Mallory thanks to
you I can retrieve my phantom phone
Jesus Christ now it's time to destroy
YouTube world I'm just kidding if I do
that I would no longer have a job did
you really think it's gonna be that easy
I am the roll around the world the king
of YouTube I am you too but you to visit
me I make more money in one video
than you will ever use and you fat-ass
will never be able to handle the
pressure of being the king so [ __ ]
truth this game spit no I never lied to
you all this time it was just a frag the
camera is right there bro hey I will
make a lot of money with this video now
go back where you came from
oh my god
I love the avatar it so cute
I suck Aaron Aaron and and thanks to
Kiwi tastic 94 and tutorials by Hugo and
of course for a competition of all the
videos I made me laugh if your friend
should go check my channel I ran it all
best dad ever
Cebu a day for say and
mech chain and well fair enough you made
an awesome game I appreciate that you
did that all that works really like it
was really creative and original the
backstory of Malcolm and why he hate
Peter pie now we now got two more let's
check them out this game is called pewds
Z diamond button
sounds interesting let's play oh god
this [ __ ] track let's do it playing
dramatic hip-hop instrumental this game
this is me
why is my moustache so goddamn pink
let's go it never mind let's go here
never mind let's go here never mind
this game what the [ __ ] where you think
you're going
no one just steps on our territory and
leaves oh my god that's right ugly ass
where you a sink it going you came to
the wrong neighborhood [ __ ]
Jesus damn it the notorious duck gang
from Norway I thought walking alone
through a suspicious neighborhood would
have saved me from this possibility this
is so well written I love it wait why
would I think that don't [ __ ] filo
Phil's a little racist
ya dumb [ __ ] hey that's my line another
[ __ ]
this cracker feisty yeah he feisty
shut up remote this is definitely racist
and you addicted to porn too teve on a
main breadcrumb porn is high-quality
entertainment Wade it's not a thing oh
it's definitely a thing well rule 34
Jesus Christ Yvonne shut this digger up
Ramone we don't use that kind of
language
that [ __ ] is going on especially to an
old friend
Bob the dark is that you Bob you know
these Swedish French yes mean him fought
in the first battle of war
I got a whole or set up apparently hate
to break up your shitty dialogue yeah
but if you're the pewdiepie guy you must
have a lot of money on your ass well we
gonna be taking it right driven let's
chuck him up Ramone goddamn it I'm so
[ __ ] sick of that baseline dude way I
died Trayvon Ramone what the hell guys
he's a friend
you all right to Norway [ __ ] Norway duck
sweden [ __ ] Sweden [ __ ] yeah kill one of
them
oh [ __ ] I'm taking a lot of damage [ __ ]
you Josh
[ __ ] you I told y'all [ __ ] you one day
but you [ __ ] ducks I [ __ ] you I
[ __ ] a duck true von Ramme Oh what the
hell guys he's a friend
glory to nor awake Trayvon your Ramon
I've always loved you why just leave
before it gets weirder than it already
is
I remember being forced to read a fanfic
like this before
I do all right let's go here hey where
are we here thanks Bob
I'll be off nappy pipe here it's and
good luck see you on the other side
perhaps the hell is that DMX great Oh
Deadpool there's so much copyright in
one second they're my channel just had a
seizure you can bet your sweet balls it
is did this game already has enough
copyright oh my god that's what I said
so from now on I am Senor PO one moment
please
how the Hat to be honest the game
developer is just getting lazy
well thanks I'll be off now I have a
little [ __ ] to catch you do that I'll
just be running my store
wait Deadpool just became a [ __ ]
store vendor what can I get my favorite
Swedish meatball stop calling me a
Swedish meatball I'll have five Swedish
meatballs please good luck and may the
force be with you wait wrong reference
where the hell is sis is this supposed
to be YouTube HQ wait this chair this
fan no no I thought it was done after
for I won't never again the plot twists
it's an f5 hello hello hello chef dad
how come our parents after my fourth
official of five nights at Freddy's game
why wouldn't you I keep making more
think of all the money I make believe it
beautify you are no longer king of
YouTube I am what do I do these metal
furs will wake up any moment and tear my
butthole open Felix
yessss neo who said that it is I neo
from the matrix oh hey what's up I came
to tell you that none of this is real
whatever do you mean
it is a game within your life within the
game or maybe a life within a game
within a game or maybe just get on with
it I'm saying on life standards finest
math you can walk around and beat the
enemy tronics now go Felix the fate of
YouTube is in your hands
don't do meth kids or cocaine wait I
keep an entire mix and getting drug
cartel within my body what the [ __ ] got
any weed I'm really questioning in my
life choices right now let's swear
that's my special attack swearing
holy [ __ ] that was awesome call the chef
dad hey Red Bull obtained dine on my
oven baked
Abyan behind Jesus no give me that dick
no oh my god I do not need to see that
let me eat that booty like a cupcake
let's cut that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah we got
chica oh God
black Freddy why not surprise
[ __ ] I find it extremely racist
that each Freddy is defined by its color
alone
your face is racist babe [ __ ] I'm
starting to think this is a bad idea to
let you bros have any form of control
over my channel and what I do
the Swedish meatballs turns into an
above average Swedish guy use it I'm
gonna have to pull out my Swedish
meatball my trump card
oh oh yeah Swedish meatball all the way
yeah get [ __ ] black Freddy and no
raises wait that's the developer I
obtained a mega dildo by everyone I beat
those three [ __ ] how many more are
there five nights more Jesus yeah no
wait white so listen I'm the guy working
on this game honestly I'm a lazy
developer than you Scott so yeah you two
just find it odd so I can wrap this game
up and Felix can get the dime and play
about him he'll have to win first
he will [ __ ] you and your dumb ass are
patema good game but Final Fantasy 7
music please don't copyright me
of course Malcolm of course Malcolm that
son of a [ __ ] comes to the fauna woods
woody pine no not Malcolm goddamnit
FedEx delivery guy you stole my bottom
malcolm 1466 he has finally arrives he's
going to get revenge revenge for what
now more like the riders didn't think
that far
[ __ ] you but wait so you did all this
for nothing
what the [ __ ] is the point of all this
give me my goddamn play button before I
shove a sharp object up your rectum I
did throwing behind me oh [ __ ] sar Wars
just started playing [ __ ] just got real
you were the chosen troll Malcolm it was
supposed to bring me my butt anyway so
the game is finished Hugh I thought this
[ __ ] excuse of a game was gonna go on
for another 20 minutes
oh so that's how it is a alright how
about another final boss give me a sec
and who is the boss supposed to be one
cannot refer to me as who for that would
dictate a singular being I am the
culmination of the greatest mind in
existence
I am the Illuminati what I was getting
good ah ah [ __ ] me we're fighting me
alone all right I think it's time you
had it you two to the next generation
and let them decide the best for it
darlin till the last moment goodbye my
one true love we're fighting the
Illuminati okay great I guess I'll just
swear it [ __ ] is it soundtrack [ __ ] I
should have stocked up on meat balls
don't have any more goddamn it I'm
[ __ ]
all right we got this there we go check
hey Felix is Elias whoa how this is
impossible well I mean not really it is
a game after all
just finish me up gladly wait don't
actually what what is happening my dad
would play button [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
well it's just it's just you wait
well it's just me and you my diamond
friend I'll see you in afterlife oh my
god ah it's 4:00 p.m. I gotta get a
video out man turns up camera okay don't
[ __ ] it up like yesterday's intro the
hell man how's it going bros my name is
Pierre fat baby and I did [ __ ] it up and
today I have something spit goddamnit
I'm Cammy chef then I'm coming well a
good job you got through this beautiful
piece of [ __ ] I call a game hope you
weren't too bored it was a bit long but
I enjoyed it that's like the Jade of a
game I told I told like don't make it
too complicated and it seems like people
really took it apart and I appreciate
that it was really cool thank you this
beautiful beautiful being for making
this game Bruce I am so proud of you for
making these games
I'm so happy having such awesome fans
who create funny or an original and
crazy [ __ ] like this I love that so
thank you so much if you watch this and
thanks to everyone who was participating
in this even if I didn't play your game
I really really appreciate all the work
and effort that you bros spend around
whatever it is I do here online
it's amazing and I'm so humbled by it
thank you don't forget to leave a like
if you enjoyed this video I get more
likes that way and as always real fast
oh boy I could do this all day all day I
can do up and down my arm doesn't even
get tired oh this feels great what this
feels fantastic I love it yeah hey oh I
didn't know your penis the dark boots